the movie starts as a group of Navy
SEALs is told that they will be going on
a mission to save Dr Howard Plummer
whose Serbian Fighters have taken when
they got the order they attacked the
enemy and Lieutenant Shane wolf who was
able to free Howard as they came out he
shows him a picture of his kids and
tells him their names but he doesn't
seem to get excited and tells him to
move on Shane gets hurt and the
professor dies in The counter-attack
before they can continue their trip
Shane gets better after two months and
his Commander Bill Fosse gives him a new
task Bill stops him from getting his
team together because it's a top secret
task and he can't tell anyone else about
it Shane was getting ready for the job
but he remembered that Bill had told him
that the professor's name had been found
on a safety deposit box in Zurich as the
rest of the team and the professor's
Widow plan to look for the box he is
asked to stay at the professor's house
in Bethesda to protect his children from
the enemy and look for the secret
project the ghost Shane gets there and
Julie the professor's wife is there to
greet him she shows him to Kate Zoe Seth
and Peter and tells them he will take
care of them while she is away Shane is
a little confused when he sees four kids
but the nanny quickly shows him there
that they are actually five when he
meets Tyler after talking to Julie about
the kids first he does his job and sets
up the Protection Systems around the
house Julie tells her kids goodbye and
heads to Zurich but not before telling
them to do what he says she worries
about leaving the kids alone but Shane
and Nanny reassure her they will be fine
while she's gone he returns to work but
he hears one of the kids screaming he
runs to the living room but everyone is
going about their day he gets mad at how
careless they are and tells them they
need to be punished but they don't seem
to care at all at night he sees someone
outside and catches a guy named Scott
and before he can ask anything Zoe comes
out and tells him that it's her
boyfriend Scott Shane teaches them
discipline and trains them after he sees
that they don't listen to his orders the
following day he wakes them up at six
and tells them to meet at the dining
room table he also makes them wear
special security bands soon he realizes
that Seth isn't at the meeting so he
angrily breaks down Seth's door to get
him out but Seth comes out of the
bathroom and starts yelling at him for
breaking the door Zoe and Seth decide to
get rid of him after seeing this they
spill oil on the stairs but the poor
Nanny gets hurt when Julie and the team
get the xeric they find the box but
can't open it because they need to know
the password Nanny chooses to quit after
falling down the stairs but he doesn't
want her to leave because he can't take
care of the kids by himself as he fights
with her to keep her from going out the
door Julie calls him and says she might
need to stay a few more days he tries
his hardest but she bites him and runs
out of the house leaving him at the
hands of the kids he tells them that
their mother will be staying for a long
time in the meantime Zoe and Seth's
School calls and asks him to meet with
their Vice director after listening to
the call Shane packs up his kids and
gets them ready for school he takes them
all in a minivan he makes it to school
just in time and meets the vice
principal Dwayne Murney however mernie
starts yelling at the kids for being
late to class he keeps talking but
principal Claire stops him and tells him
to go outside and look over the school
she sends the kids to class and tells
him that Julie has our already told her
what's happening so she also lets him
stay at school and watch over the
children he stops the bullies from
hurting Seth but Dwayne says Seth needs
to learn how to protect himself Shane
tries to help set the escape the vice
principal's jokes but Seth doesn't want
his help Claire comes over to him but he
gets a message about an emergency and
has to leave quickly he goes to the
signal but when he arrives he finds that
the kids have thrown their wristbands
into the sewer he is in a bad mood when
he gets to the house he shows the kids
the note but he doesn't say anything
this time because of Claire Shane
returns from taking a shower and sees a
lot of kids at the dinner table they
start making fun of him Kate tells him
that they come over once a week and will
stay until 8 pm he doesn't want to let
them stay but he does and tells them
what to do Kade is picked on by some
boys at school but he tells her he will
protect her Shane finally gets home and
sees Zoe and her friends having a party
he tells them to stop right away they
try to get out of the house quickly but
he makes them clean up and make it as
clean as possible he watches them clean
it and finds a CD with the word ghost
written on it he puts it in his pocket
Zoe gets into another fight with him and
and tells him to leave them alone
someone breaks into the house before
they can say anything else so he tells
the kids to lock themselves in a room he
fights with them and they must leave the
house because of it after getting rid of
them he returned to the room to tell the
kids that they were safe they ran to him
for safety and asked them to not leave
them alone Seth asks them what they want
and they say the CD the kids finally
agree to let him live with them and
listen to him he is called the school
again and the director tells him that
Seth has dyed his hair and hasn't been
to wrestling practice in over a month
Claire tells him that Seth and Zoe have
been having some mental problems so she
asks him to talk to them and find out
what's happening when he gets home from
school he asks Seth about wrestling Seth
tells him that it's not what he wants to
do and that he's only doing it because
his father told them to Shane goes to
Seth's room to talk to him but when he
gets there he finds that Seth has run
away so Shane goes after Seth after
telling Zoe to take care of the other
kids he follows Seth and finds him in a
local theater where he practices for a
play the director however leaves the
seat because he is not happy with the
actress performances he goes over to
Seth who thinks he won't understand his
drive but promises to support him and
let him do whatever he wants Shane
agrees to take over and direct the show
for Seth because he worries about the
director he starts to get closer with
the kids he tells them bedtime stories
and dances with Peter to help him fall
asleep just like Peter's father used to
do he tells Zoe the next day that he
knows she's always wanted to drive the
car at school he tell Dwayne that he
quit wrestling to work in a musical play
and tells Seth to stand up to Dwayne
Shane decides to wrestle with him
despite his anger at him for giving up
on wrestling the fight breaks out but he
quickly knocks the other kid to the
ground while caring for Tyler he trains
Kate and her friends assists Seth with
his acting and teaches Zoe to drive he
expresses his love for Shame by thanking
Peter and calling him daddy while he
dances for him at night when Kate and
her pals are bullied once more they
fight back and knock the boys down using
the strategies they learned from him the
password Angel which is written on
Julie's ring is ultimately deciphered
they successfully obtain the box from
the officials and once inside they
discovered a two-pronged key Shane finds
Zoe sitting alone in a room at home and
tries to talk to her at first she
remains silent but later she speaks out
and tells him how much she misses her
father after a while he gets a call from
Julie who informs him that she will
return home shortly after being shocked
by the news he watches as they finally
return to a normal life and began
organizing a welcome home party for her
he finds an underground vault in the
garage the same day and phones his
office to let him know that it needs a
two-pronged key to open when Julie
finally returns to the house the kids
throw a surprise party for her bill
follows Shane to the garage but they are
attacked before they can access the
Vault Shane immediately recognizes the
attackers as the neighbors Mr and Mrs
Chun but to his surprise Bill also joins
them they imprison Julie the children
and Bill inside the home where Bill
confesses to working for North Korea
they open the vault with Julie by their
side but are halted by the sophisticated
security system after a little while the
children managed to free themselves and
wake Shane when instruct them to contact
the police while he looks for their
mother as they drive off in the minivan
Mr Chun begins pursuing them in Bill's
vehicle after battling Bill and Chun
Shane arrives to assist drooling and
realizes that Peter's dance is the key
to entry he then opens the lock kids
trick the police into going into the
house after they pass by the school but
Mr Chun shows up and demands that they
turn over the ghost while brandishing a
gun while Claire is able to kill him
Shane distracts him by ordering his pet
duck Gary to attack him she assists him
and he Praises her but Kate Cuts them
off she shows him her affection by
giving him a snapshot of The Sibling so
he will never forget them the vice
principal Dwayne plays a nun in Seth's
musical production which they all attend
after retiring from the Navy Shane
joined the school as a wrestling coach
which he tells Claire about he commends
Seth for his accomplishments click on
one of the two videos on screen right
now
[Music]
foreign